Today's pick for the little yellow book
is one for anyone
who likes to keep their hands clean,
as well as their conscience.
It's Blueland's,
Mickey and friends, hand soap kit.
It's an $18 investment,
but here's what you get,
a glass bottle that you permanently keep
and then you get the little refills.
And what I love about this is
I'm a big Blueland fan,
they're one of my favorite
environmentally conscientious brands,
but this is a great way to get your kids
thinking in the right direction.
So this is a great time to get your kids started
on planet saving tips.
So this is planet saving
because you're making it in a glass jar you keep,
you're not throwing away the plastic soap container,
right?
I am so awake when it comes to plastic
and trying to find the alternatives,
because I want there to be a planet
for my kids.
Yeah.
And I think this is just a great,
optimistic, fun way to do it.
And if you go to the Blueland website,
you'll also find heaps
of just the most amazing products.
They are truly one of my favorite companies.
And I think now we get our kids started
on the right track,
which feels really good.
And by the way,
good for you Blueland, getting a collab with Disney.
Nice!
(loud laughter)
Yeah.
So thank you so much for joining us
you guys today,
it has been such a pleasure and a privilege
to hang out with you
and for anyone who may be watching at home or on the go,
please take this energy with you.
We hope that you have a fantastic day
and just yeah, have a good one.
Bye everybody.
(loud applause)
(upbeat music)